what started as a ripple caused by the
collapse of a little-known finance
company
has led to waves in westminster there
are now seven
separate inquiries into issues linked to
the green sill scandal
far beyond the control of boris johnson
and his boardman inquiry
i think the most important thing is for
us to
get to the bottom of it uh properly and
uh
i want all ministers and civil servants
to be making you know the information
that needs to be known
and known to mr baldwin the rules on
lobbying and conflicts of interest
are highly likely to be toughened up but
this is also
about the culture in westminster a place
where it's partly
about who you know access is important
contacts
a currency and that is why questions are
now being asked
about senior figures not just in past
administrations but in the current one
too
bill crothers has been much criticized
this week he was a civil servant running
government procurement who for a few
months
worked for green sill too but one of the
man who appointed him
that was francis moored then the top
cabin office minister
in david cameron's government simone
finn was mr moore's special adviser
in 2015 david cameron gave both maude
and finn
seats in the house of lords they later
founded francis maud associates
a private consultancy firm which advises
government on
issues like procurement but both are now
back in government although they retain
their shareholdings in the company
baron moored is conducting a review into
how whitehall operates
baroness finn was this year appointed
boris johnson's deputy chief of staff
she has declared her outside interests
but some call this
the revolving door it's not a revolving
door it's an open door now into
government
we need increased powers we need more
and stronger lobbying rules
what we've got is lobbying rules that
obviously aren't working
the ex-minister tasked with policing the
jobs of those leaving government
says a culture change needs to come from
the top those who have power
have a have a responsibility to set
a very clear term because you know
the way in which an organization runs is
reflected to what the people at the top
where seven inquiries go an eighth could
follow
with public spending watchdog the
national audit office
now considering whether to launch their
own investigation
for now those waves continue joe pike
sky news westminster